[Musik]
dschibuti ostafrika das ist die
wahlheimat von cornelia frey
die bernerin hat große pläne aber wenig
finanziellen mitteln als regisseurin
realisiert sie mit einheimischen filmen
sie komponiert singt lieder und ist
beseelt von einer mission
doch der ex ortschaft war ziemlich
schräg lüge betrüge der hier jeder über
kommt und das werde ich deshalb wandert
eine schweizerin nach afrika aus wie
sieht ihr alltag aus und wie
verwirklicht sich jemand in einem der
ärmsten länder der welt
davon handelt diese reportage
cornelia vrees geschichte beginnt im
bernischen langenthal in diesem haus
hier verbrachte sie ihre jugend hier
wuchsen auch ihre drei kinder auf einmal
im jahr kommt sie jeweils zurück zu
ihren wurzeln
die geschiedene auswanderin besucht ihre
mutter tot die frau die noch immer hier
wohnt zu gast ist auch sohn silas
bitterli ein künstler in afrika war der
32 jährige noch nie erlebt seine
abenteuerlust in selbst gemalten bildern
aus und wenn es ganz schlimm gewesen
irgendwie macht sowieso vorsieht sich
das finanzielle aus
die bisher im luxus das kann man im
nachhinein warum ich gegangen oder
kollegen diskutieren weil ich vor ort
und werde automarkt hoch folgt jetzt
langsam tadschura
am gleichnamigen golf im kleinstaat
dschibuti ortschaft zählt 22.000
einwohner und ein vielfaches an ziegen
[Musik]
die menschen hier sind muslime
sie gehören zum volk der av seit zehn
jahren lebt cornelia frey auf dem
schwarzen kontinent nur wenige der
hiesigen menschen beherrschen eine
fremdsprache
deshalb war es für sie ein muss die
sprache der afar zu lernen
die fähre liegt nur zwei mal pro woche
an die zufahrtstraße ist schlecht
ausgebaut und oft nicht befahrbar
sie ist die einzige weiße im abgelegenen
ort
wenn jetzt der die touren
das war schwierig mit castor bleiben
dschibuti ist ein stark
unterentwickeltes land das
gesundheitssystem und die infrastruktur
liegen am boden
mehr als 60 prozent der bevölkerung
haben keine arbeit
die arbeitsrechtlichen überwiegen
anschluss regiert wird der kleinstadt
durch ein autoritäres regime
[Gelächter]
cornelia frey versucht sich hier als
künstlerin zu etablieren
unter anderem macht sie musik dabei
bezieht sie die einheimische bevölkerung
mit ein
ein bestimmtes thema ob es wirklich
liebe du bist du und wir beschäftigen
[Musik]
dieses stück hat die schweizerin
zusammen mit einheimischen komponiert
und arrangiert
leider ist ihr video wieder im fernsehen
zu sehen noch im radio zu hören denn sie
will geld dafür
[Musik]
hinter der heutigen künstlerin liegt
eine abwechslungsreiche karriere
kochlehre wirte prüfung handels diplom
kaufmännische angestellte als ihre
kinder flügge wurden ließ sie das leben
in wohlstand hinter sich und zog nach
afrika hier kommt sie mit monatlich 400
franken aus trotzdem sind finanzielle
engpässe ein dauerthema
wenn jetzt braucht das vertrauen in gott
vertrauen aus
die schweizerin ist eine
überlebenskünstlerin ihr fällt immer
etwas ein um ein paar dschibuti von zu
verdienen braucht und was machen sie
denn hier als hochzeit heißt das wo ich
man stundenlang musik mache ich als
instrumente mir für die ente für die
erneute bvb hatte das gebiet win
situation
[Musik]
der jura hat als zweitgrößte stadt des
landes nur gerade zwei einkaufsläden im
unfruchtbaren dschibuti müssen selbst
lebensmittel wie gemüse und früchte
importiert werden dschibuti ist seit
drei jahren cornelia face heimat zuvor
lebte sie sieben jahre lang in äthiopien
dort gründete sie ein kinderheim
das kinderheim in äthiopien wird durch
spendengelder finanziert einen lohn
beziehen sie keinen sagt cornelia frey
sie ist zwar nach wie vor die leiterin
doch vor ort ist sie nur noch selten
grund die terror-organisation al shabab
morgen frau und kind und ruhiger
ich glaube doch
50 liter fass spital gebracht
ich bin also bis jetzt ist es richtig
auch dieselbe bietet jetzt das gebiet wo
somali um darf sie und der krise josi
dior hat die zur posse zwischen
südstraße wieder gestört und so und der
dritte wahlgang wieder schlüpft aber
jetzt plötzlich total easy tones mit dem
tresor und jetzt ist mit yello heute
bitte stoppt und so aber wieder verboten
in dschibuti fand die lebenskünstlerin
für sich eine neue herausforderung
nebst ihre musik projekten realisiert
sie mit einheimischen soaps sie filmt
und bearbeitet ihre werke gleich selber
[Musik]
die szene ist rosé und das motorrad vom
kaffee im restaurant auf die straße wo
sie sich treffen und zu völlig verliert
und wie das so widersprach zu und hat
gott das ist noch interessant
hans sigl beginnen so verliebt den
afrika cup aus leeds
das passt gar nicht cd ist abend der
schotte so liege diese verliehen er ist
mit ihren gedanken weiter vorstellen
wenn sie jetzt möchte ich etwas gedanken
doch univeg für jede kommune für europa
die hätte auf der suche nach netto also
das noch nicht so
durch eigentlich wären heute weitere
dreharbeiten ihrer romanze geplant das
ic naturkatastrophe hat auch eigentliche
frage ist reine krawalltouristen
kraftfahrzeuge aufnahmen machen
fourcade und der jahressieger moment
also wünschen der affäre
und dennoch so viel wurde
am nächsten tag
telefon
er probiert doch selbst eine trage dann
noch mit
sauber
also als großes gehäuse sorgt jetzt auch
spielerisch sie kommt ja die
laienschauspielerinnen wohnt in einem
gemauerten haus ohne dach
die 17-jährige zafira ali hassan ist die
hauptdarstellerin in der miniserie
cornelia frey bespricht mit ihr den
heutigen drehtag
aber zu hause sind großartig ja extrem
das ist aber mit sehr guten zahlen und
habe bis auf strom installiert das
fordert strom soll saphir als nächstes
erhalten
die schweizerin unterstützte sie schon
oft die beiden frauen kennen sich seit
zwei jahren aufgrund der dreharbeiten
sehen sie sich häufig cornelia liegt
zwar noch nicht lange hier
aber sie versteht unsere tradition
unterwegs zum heutigen die
darstellerinnen setzen cornelia vrees
ideen spontan um ein drehbuch gibt es
nicht meistens ist die szene nach dem
ersten versuch im kasten
es sei den zorn gäste stören die
aufnahmen
ich würde gerne ein star werden und geld
verdienen wenn sie wetter
aber der dortige sind doch da das jetzt
repariert und wäre das nicht das hört zu
messen das heißt sie gehen aber statt
klasse wartet bereits die nächste szene
gespielt wird ein streit zwischen saphir
und ihrem mann
er hat ihr ein leben in saus und braus
versprochen jetzt stellt sich heraus
dass er schulden hat saphir fühlt sich
hintergangen
eine szene die typisch sei für dschibuti
betont die bernerin
sie versteht sich als aufklärerin das
sagte sich der sache und
was der lüge und betrug und gesellschaft
laubbäumen die thermische wachsen
derzeit mit das gar nicht und da braucht
man country voraus wo das vorzeige
[Musik]
heraus du störst die aufnahmen sagt sie
zum nächsten störenfried verschwindet
sagt safina zu ihrem mann
ich lasse mich von der scheibe der
gespielte streit mündete draußen für die
17 jährige schauspielerin in eine reale
belästigung und episode mit ihm
irgendwie durch eine kleine siedlung ist
schauplatz der nächsten szene
und jetzt singt er ist hier also muss
ich sagen die vom gerät selber aber imho
was immer wir werden die giftstoffe
wurde trägt aber eben genau nicht am
fernseher warum man es noch nicht sagt
hey wie mach jetzt staffel hat sie eine
botschaft von der liebe und musik prof
mit dem kauf und die chance flüchtlinge
vollamtlich abgesetzt
wollen wir im ramadan hat zwei wochen
fest oft herrschen im bruchweg spät
das sieht der neue chef patrick arbeitet
und so sehr zwischen lässigkeit es gibt
für neue chef
und wenn sie stark hält er gibt korn ist
erika forster ausprobiert wie immer
braucht es ganz sauber verbucht das
problem würde ein paar tage später
[Musik]
richtig sachen ersetzt werden
groß ist die universa bekannt zu
schaffen
also wie sie die große chance jetzt
extrem
[Musik]
die reise zum national fernsehen in die
hauptstadt dschibuti des gleichnamigen
landes dauerte einen halben tag
nun geht sie hoffnungsvoll zum
vereinbarten termin dann die
ernüchterung weiter als in den warteraum
kommt sie nicht
ein paar minuten später draußen vor der
tv-station basiertes gar nicht mehr
sehen und sich die türkei wurde
präsident gerade
was machen die sich seit diesen
aufnahmen sind ein paar monate vergangen
cornelia frey steht inzwischen auch mit
anderen fernsehstationen in kontakt man
drei begeistert von ihrer so sagt die
lebenskünstlerin doch verkaufen konnte
sie die filme bisher nicht
[Musik]